françois mitterrand le tgv est un
élément essentiel de l'aménagement du
territoire sur les dix plus grandes
entreprises 7 appartiennent à l'état
antenne de midi les habitants de la zup
se rencontrent et se parlent et
messieurs bonsoir dans la grande
histoire des chemins de fer une
naissance est un baptême aujourd'hui
ceux du tgv ce train super rapide dont
les premiers pas sur le papier au monde
à déjà 13 ans tgv trains à grande
vitesse en effet 2h40 pour relier lyon
et paris deux heures dans moins de deux
ans songez au début du siècle il en
fallait 7h30
aujourd'hui un conducteur très
particulier françois mitterrand et dans
la rame une foule d'invités françois
mitterrand qui a fait un discours pour
expliquer que le tgv comme d'autres
services publics doit permette de créer
des emplois d'affronter la concurrence
internationale
ils sont aussi at il dit une vitrine
l'arrivée du tgv en replaçant la région
sur un grand itinéraire international
attirera des activités nouvelles et
créera des emplois moyen de transport
remarquable parfaitement adaptée aux
besoins de déplacements dans la gamme
des distances intermédiaires
le tgv représente c'est ceci doit être
sans cesse rappeler une grande
réalisation technique
une étape de plus dans la recherche par
l'homme de son propre dépassement un
signe pour le monde entier que la france
entend demeurer une grande nation
innovatrice bien placé dans la course
aux technologies de pointe
la france ne surmonte eura pa les
difficultés économiques sans
entreprendre
as tu es fort de renouveau industriel
qui suppose
à la fois les données générales indiqué
par le premier ministre et le
gouvernement au cours de ces quatre
derniers mois mais aussi et de façon
précise l'augmentation prévue dans le
budget des fonds consacrés à la
recherche mais aussi le développement
mais aussi la relance de
l'investissement productif afin de
moderniser nos usines pour affronter la
concurrence internationale et
reconquérir le marché intérieur la sncf
et les autres grands services publics
comme la poste qui pourrait utiliser ce
nouvel équipement contribueront de la
même manière à assurer des plans de
charge réguliers et des emplois stables
aux fournisseurs et conforteront la base
industrielle sans laquelle il sera
impossible d'exporter le prénom un
public ne va plus tarder maintenant à
reprendre le train il arrivera à paris
aux alentours de 23h30 vous pourrez
vivre la fin de ce parcours dans notre
dernier journal mais malheureusement je
ne tente pas de dossiers de l'écran de
très mauvaises conditions métérologiques
n'ayant pas permis de procéder à toutes
les répétitions techniques nécessaires
au déroulement normal de l'émission tout
devait être relayé par hélicoptère
antenne 2 et la sfp sons sont très déçus
mais c'est comme ça en attendant leur
portage tout chaud que nous envoie à
nouveau et spéciaux berlin pradino et
jean ville
pour le chef de l'état la france n'a pas
renoncé a étonné le monde par les
prouesses de ses ingénieurs et la
capacité de ces travailleurs grâce au
tgv lyon est aujourd'hui à 2h40 de paris
et l'an prochain à 2 heures seulement
le tgv a rappelé monsieur mitterrand est
une réalisation décidé par d'autres
responsables politiques qui ont agi
utilement pour le pays en cette
circonstance c'est aussi le fait de
milliers d'ouvriers et de techniciens et
d'ingénieurs français plusieurs
ministres du gouvernement ont participé
à cette journée d'inauguration des
leaders politiques comme monsieur
marchait le ministre des transports
monsieur fiterman qui au départ de paris
a subi sa première manifestation
une centaine de militants de la cfdt
défenseur des wagons lits
c'est à lyon que le président de la
république a rejoint les invités et les
personnalités
c'est là qu'il a rendu hommage aux
cheminots de la sncf
ce grand service public explique
monsieur mitterrand doit être développé
et modernisé le train est un élément
irremplaçable dans la gamme des moyens
de transport offert aux français la sncf
dans sa nouvelle convention avec l'état
doit servir d'exemple de contribution au
progrès économique de la nation
les investissements du chemin de fer
seront maintenues à un niveau élevé la
sncf prépare un tgv atlantique
rennes à deux heures de paris bordeaux à
trois puis plus tard liaisons vers le
nord est peut-être londres le tgv est
aussi pour le chef de l'état
un moyen de créer des emplois il le dira
un peu plus tard au creusot dans son
discours à 260 km/heure monsieur
mitterrand va non seulement conduire
pendant quelques minutes le train de
l'inauguration mais aussi parlé avec le
personnel de la sncf roulant et
ingénieurs du tgv
encore un mot donc pour vous rappeler
que ce matin une cinquantaine de
syndicalistes de la cgt avaient
manifesté gare de lyon avant le départ
du train l'actualité décidément lyonnais
ce soir puisque le journal antenne 2010
nous avions un petit peu improvisé un
studio en plein air à vénissieux pour
essayer de comprendre un peu mieux cette
violence rampante qui dégradent là-bas
et le matériel et surtout les rapports
humains depuis deux mois
pour ce faire nous avions interrogé des
différents protagonistes le maire les
institutions toutes les parties
concernées dialogue qu'ils ont peut-être
un petit peu compartimenté et puis tout
d'un coup la fin d'émission alors que
nous étions en train de rendre l'antenne
une soif de parole de la part de ceux
qu'on n'entend pas toujours et vous
allez voir à nouveau un dialogue qui
s'instaure chaotique passionnés mais
aussi riche d'enseignements
regardez le nombre d'arguments échanger
part et d'autre en moins de 3 min
écoutez jeunes écoutent et une maltais
belle jeune arabe ce qu'on avait subi
les ainsi que le but subissent encore
les discriminations dans le travail le
logement le racisme qui est de partout
nous promettant que tout le temps
reculer leur faisant confiance moi je
venais parce que j'y vis ma femme peut
se promener reçoit les infâmes notre
propre histoire
moi je ne risque rien je sais que je
fais comme si j'étais inquiet car on ne
leur fait pas confiance on a même une
équipe
je suis d'accord avec vous mais quand
vous voyez que la nuit vous êtes obligés
de monter la garde
- c'est dire devant votre véhicule ça ma
peau mais lendemain matin chaque année
le boucau le rouleau ensemble avant
qu'un jour on a volé le riz que
l'encadrement leur dispute avec les
jeunes
voilà voilà ces treize voiliers voyez je
suis d'accord mais pour garder notre
point de vue nous jamais ce qu ça existe
il ya des embrouilles à la tuque jamais
jamais on nous a demandé notre avis nous
nous élevons des cours que ce soit en
direct les journalistes ou même à papier
ils ont commandé par ici qui comme
n'ayant nullement des sept arpents soir
du magasin quand on descend de chez nous
l'amour comme lui parler
oui la duchère à passer quand je ne
comprends pas c'est qu'on cohabite avec
ses jantes au pirée colère parce que les
deux ouvriers comme eux mmm a volé ma
voiture 3 franck un jour la troisième
fonds mena complètement incendié brûlé
belge conseillent l'admissible c'est mon
outil de travail
tous les jours on se côtoie comme un
bouffon sarano dans la journée la parade
ou si je subis la délinquance enrichit
algéro j'allais du monde puisque son
sein quelques heureux je suis dit la
délinquance et collants mallard les que
des fractures brûler des fous et 215 et
monsieur lecard nous mon père il a
commerce vient d'ouvrir un iej mois du
mai est bien venu voir la misère au
moins pas par les jeunes crevettes pas
ont les moyens sur la route mais là il
crève la faim mais intérieurement ils
sont tous dans la mine mais ces univers
intérieur n'est pas le musée les rangs
derrière on fait des misères mais peu
d'élus cherchons à nous tous les mois
les carreaux cassés mais pas tous les
cas c'est tout ce qui est cassé
faucon et paye c'est nous qu'on et
pénales mais je sais bien la gamme en
effet des projets java pendant trois
gars là il faut vraiment qu'on fasse
quelque chose
du boulot pour les jeunes et moins
jeunes qu'ils aillent à l'école ils
puissent avoir un métier un avenir je me
rendais compte à 20 ans avait été un an
pour travailler mais vous avez rien
qu'un beau temps c'est que notre ami
soir ils veulent sortir les boîtes sont
refusés pour les arabes les merlus
d'abord dire de sauce maintenant une
nouvelle loi que tous les enfants qui
sont nés à partir de bâle iii ont une
carte d'identité brevets il se présente
en moins pour yves rossy a cédé à
ralentir énormément sa carte d'identité
et quand tu voyais que ces français ont
dit on accepte les clients s'est il
amusé droit mais qu'est ce qu'on en dit
long creux mais ils sont là de plus de
30 ans mais on n'est pas des drogués et
non chercher à jouer ensuite le maire de
vénissieux qui était reparti ou la tête
vu dès le début de ce dialogue et qui a
certainement des arguments échangés il
est ce soir dans le train et nous
attendons une réponse dans le journal
antenne de midi de demain
il a accepté d'ores et déjà de recevoir
des jeunes chez lui en attendant pour
vous qui étiez pour nous qui nous
regardions bernard langlois qu'elles le
sont oui je crois que c'est les images
qui parlent un peu tout seul et je dois
vous dire que le dialogue en plus c'est
continuer encore pas mal de temps après
l'émission
qu'est ce qu'on a voulu faire dans la
voulais faire une expérience directe à
chaud nous l'avons et c'est ça qui est
un petit peu nouveau on a un peu mélangé
les touches les torchons et les
serviettes s'il ose dire c'est à dire
d'un côté les notables les élus les
représentants autorisés de la parole
publique et de l'autre les anonymes ceux
qui n'ont jamais l'occasion de
s'exprimer alors évidemment c'est
quelquefois plus explosif vous venez de
le voir et ça demande de la part de tout
le monde je crois de la part des
notables des anonymes de nous aussi les
journalistes ça demande une adaptation
sa demande peut-être qu'on bouscule un
peu nos habitudes faut savoir écouter
voilà mais je crois que ça en vaut la
peine en attendant maintenant avec
daniel leconte le point sur l'enquêté
décidé quelques heures après le drame du
cs de peyrol ce soir une information
contre x a été ouverte les
responsabilités ne sont pas faciles à
déterminer
c'était le cs de pérols en provence un
édifice modèles construits en dur et
inaugurée il ya huit jours à peine c'est
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en reste après
l'explosion un amas de béton disloqué
par le souffle des ruines gardé par des
gendarmes vigilant une vision
d'apocalypse pour les habitants du
village
tremblant penser à ce qui aurait pu se
produire si l'explosion avait eu lieu
après la rentrée scolaire
ce collège nous a bien donné du mal en
fait je m'en suis occupé pour le canton
avec toute l'ardeur qui était qui
m'était possible
houle atteignant depuis dix années et
puis nous avons inauguré firme 50 ans
était hier devant un collège aussi beau
et malheureusement le destin a voulu que
rolls encore une fois éprouvé par une
catastrophe qui aurait pu être une
catastrophe nationale un plan parce que
ce vendredi 52 élèves devaient rentrer
ce matin il y avait sur les lieux de la
catastrophe les deux inscriptions de
l'éducation nationale chargé d'une
mission d'information par alain savary
les fonctionnaires de la direction
départementale de l'équipement et les
responsables des entreprises concernées
calonne
si l'on connaît les circonstances de
l'accident une explosion due à une
accumulation de gaz dans le vide
sanitaire est provoquée par un contact
électrique
on s'interroge sur les causes
installations défectueuses manipulation
d'un usager ou même malveillance
l'information promet d'être long quatre
entreprises sont en effet impliqués dans
la construction du système de chauffage
est temps que l'origine de la fuite ne
sera pas précisé il sera difficile de
définir les responsabilités dès
maintenant pourtant certaines questions
méritent d'être posées pourquoi madame
barreau la gestionnaire du cs qui
s'inquiétaient d'une forte odeur de gaz
48 heures auparavant n'a pu joindre
personne au téléphone
pourquoi la commission de sécurité a
délivré les certificats de conformité
pourquoi enfin ceci es n'était pas
équipée d'un dispositif automatique de
sécurité je crois que rien ne remplace
la vigilance de du chef d'établissement
et de l'équipe pédagogique et je crois
que quel que soit les dispositifs de
sécurité il faut également que
l'accident est toujours imprévisible il
faut qu'un dispositif d' alerte
fonctionne et fonctionnent efficacement
aujourd'hui dans les locaux du rectorat
les membres de la mission d'information
ont tenu leur première réunion ils ont
arrêté les mesures pour assurer malgré
tout la rentrée scolaire nationalisation
c'est demain que le conseil des
ministres ces virades du texte définitif
un texte remanié encore ces dernières
heures pour être à nouveau présenté
devant le conseil d'état qui a
aujourd'hui maintenues l'avis qu'il
avait rendu la semaine dernière un avis
qui proposait la nationalisation des
banques étrangères dont les dépôts
dépasse un milliard de francs et ce au
nom de l'égalité de traitement entre
étrangers et français
alors ce n'est bien sûr qu'un avis mais
est ce nous permet de voir avec jean
loup les scènes ce qu'est le rôle de
cette institution relativement méconnu
après avis du conseil d'état le conseil
d'état entendu tout projet de loi doit
porter l'une de ses dimensions il faut
dire que pour tout projet l'avis du
conseil est obligatoire même s'il n'est
pas impératif entendez par là que le
gouvernement est tenu de demander cet
avis mais n'est pas tenue de le
respecter
bref le conseil d'état est vraiment là
pour donner des avis
rien de plus pourtant dans la mesure où
il a à faire valoir les contradictions
qui peuvent exister entre un projet
précis et les lois existantes
les avis du conte
d'état sont importants car l'exécutif ne
peut ignorer les délibérations d'une des
plus anciennes institutions françaises
elles datent de 1802 napoléon bonaparte
d'une des institutions les plus
indépendantes du pouvoir même si le
gouvernement a la possibilité de
promouvoir un certain nombre de
personnalités au sein du conseil
au niveau des maîtres de requêtes et des
conseillers d'état il n'empêche
l'avis du conseil est généralement suivi
il conseille au gouvernement d'abroger
les lois existantes de renoncer à un
texte de projet de loi ou de le modifier
aujourd'hui pour les nationalisations le
gouvernement accepte de modifier le
gouvernement négocie le conseil d'état
ce soir maintient ses positions
reste à savoir qui aura le dernier mot
mais logiquement
constitutionnellement c'est le
gouvernement avec des nationalisations
bien fait a dit aujourd'hui michel
rocard la france aura seul le moyen
d'aller à contre pente pour sortir de la
crise fait que le gouvernement est
massée à 6 ter la matière l'exemple
autrichien un pays dirigé depuis onze
ans par des socialistes
et là bas un salarié sur six travaillent
dans une entreprise appartement
directement ou indirectement à l'état la
ville est assez difficile de comparer ou
d'adapter tout à fait ce modèle en
france trop de différence de taille de
mentalité de rapports sociaux entre les
deux pays une enquête d'alain doublé ce
qui est roland tourte
pour apprécier la réussite économique
d'un pays on peut citer des chiffres
emploi exportation produit national brut
par exemple mais pourquoi ne pas mesurer
plus tôt le niveau de vie des
autrichiens avec des images car enfin le
visage des gens leur habillement ce
qu'il ya dans les boutiques les voitures
les bâtiments tout cela reflète aussi
bien que les chiffres la prospérité de
ce petit pays l'autriche a connu au
cours des années 70 le taux de
croissance plus rapide d'europe
le taux d'inflation le plus bas est très
peu de chemin sur les 10 plus grandes
entreprises autrichiennes 7
appartiennent entièrement à l'état 2
sont en grande partie contrôlée par les
banques nationalisées
cela explique peut-être en grande partie
cette réussite économique et social
distinguons trois types de
nationalisation 1 les services publics
bien sûr comme dans de nombreux pays
les transports en commun la poste et
c'est également une compagnie aérienne
très florissante
il existe enfin de nombreuses
entreprises de services publics
appartenant aux autorités provinciales
ou municipales
deuxième secteur de nationalisations les
banques
près de 70% du secteur bancaire est
nationalisée depuis 1946
l'autriche est l'un des pays au monde où
il ya le plus de banques par habitant
les banques nationalisées contrôle 18%
de l'industrie d'où l'importance de leur
rôle financier industriel mais aussi de
leur responsabilité sociale serait-elle
tentée de faire passer leurs bénéfices
avant la sauvegarde des emplois dans la
plupart des pays industrialisés
il en serait ainsi bien sûr en autriche
comme nous sommes sains pays petit il y
à des réunions non formelle dans
lesquels tant des discussions non
formelle
il est possible pour le gouvernement de
convaincre les fonctionnaires poker
telle attitude et d
zaatari gouvernementale convaincre les
banques est d'aider les entreprises en
difficulté bien sûr quand une
participation industrielle a des
problèmes on va l'aider comme on est des
personnes qui sont en des problèmes mais
ce n'est pas possible pour trop
longtemps en france une telle
collaboration n'existe pas aucune
opération d'envergure planifié par
l'état n'impose un rôle particulier aux
banques nationalisées mais pourtant
concurrentes troisième type d'entreprise
nationaliser celles qui sont regroupés
en holding d'état par loïc ag société
anonyme pour l'administration de
l'industrie autrichienne loyat g emploie
115 mille personnes elle fournit le
cinquième de la production industrielle
en font partie l'industrie pétrolière
sidérurgique chimiques en grande partie
ainsi que les constructions mécaniques
et électriques
la sidérurgie est un grave sujet de
préoccupation heureusement les bénéfices
dégagés par l'industrie pétrolière
autrichienne sont là pour combler les
pertes de la sidérurgie
ici encore on trouve la double mission
industriel et social
pour le directeur de loyat g7 politique
consistant à prélever les bénéfices des
entreprises rentables pour soutenir les
autres est un handicap pourtant il
ajoute aussitôt je crois que cette
politique représente la meilleure
sécurité pour l'emploi en autriche
l'objectif va coûter cher est ce que le
maintien du plein-emploi justifie
réellement l'endettement de l'état
oui pour le directeur général
l'endettement est justifiée car le
chômage également coûte cher cher
financièrement et cher politiquement
un haut fonctionnaire de l'onu âgé nous
disait mieux vaut des dettes que lé
chômage
jusqu'où s'arrêteront les autrichiens
vive t-il au dessus de leurs moyens leur
avenir va-t-il s'assombrir
ce n'est pas sur les facultés
d'adaptation de ce petit pays sont
étonnantes
bonne n'est pas intéressé par une
réévaluation du marque voilà ce que
vient de dire ce matin la ministre
l'économie ouest allemand autre dossier
délicat sur le bureau du premier
ministre celui des radios libres qui à
maurois dit aujourd'hui au rapporteur du
projet de loi à l'assemblée de
dédramatiser de problèmes sans que la
question de la publicité ne soit pas
encore tout à fait réglé tout à l'heure
les représentants de quatre associations
de radios libres ont été reçus à
l'elysée ce que nous attendons de vous
ont-ils écrit à françois mitterrand
c'est une réalisation exemplaire qui
permettent de devancer celle de nos
voisins par la générosité de son audace
communication encore pas de pluralisme
dans la presse écrite a dit aujourd'hui
le directeur de l'humanité roland leroy
sans le développement de la presse
communiste
voilà qui nous amène à la politique
proprement invités à ce texte signé
raymond barre à paraître demain dans le
journal rhône alpes un quotidien un
texte qui marquera sans doute pour la
marle à la rentrée politique l'ancien
premier ministre
effectivement on attendait et valéry
giscard d'estaing ou jacques chirac et
c'est raymond barre qui apparaît la
démarche est discrète pas de télé pas de
radio tout juste un article dans un
quotidien régional mais un article écrit
au vitriol en groupe ou raymond barre
tout va mal tout va très mal un seul
responsable le pouvoir actuel qui dit il
a brûlé en quatre mois tous les atouts
forget avant le 10 mai autrement dit
l'indépendance énergétique
la situation des finances publiques et
le dynamisme des entreprises volant
quelques mots le réquisitoire de raymond
barre qui jusqu'à présent avaient subi
silencieux et goguenard toutes les
critiques contre l'héritage giscardien
et qui aujourd'hui pour se défendre
choisi la contre-attaqué ce n'est
peut-être pas un hasard si cet article
est publié 24 heures seulement avant la
conférence de presse de françois
mitterrand cela permet à raymond barre
d'interpeller en quelque sorte le
président de la république et de se
poser déjà en interlocuteur le fait
qu'il appelle les français à lutter en
dehors des étiquettes à l'écart des
querelles et significatif pas question
pour lui de rester sur la touche il
entend jouer un rôle est un rôle actif
mais il n'est pas le seul valéry giscard
d'estaing brûle déjà de revenir sur la
scène politique et jacques chirac créera
pas prépare sa rentrée début octobre
peine de mort une proposition de loi de
jean cluzel sénateurs 2
l'allier pour réformer la constitution
est appelé à un référendum
par ailleurs une protestation des
parents du petit philippe bertrand tué
par patrick henry et cités par le garde
des sceaux lors du débat à l'assemblée
nous n'acceptons pas écrit-il dans l'est
est clair que notre réserve soit
exploité à des fins contraires à ce que
nous pensons profondément nous ne
tolérerons jamais de croiser dans
quelques années sur les trottoirs
menottes votre notre ville l'assassin de
notre enfant jacques attali envoyé
spécial du président de la république en
israël il a vouvoyé rendu visite au
premier ministre menahem begin
il s'est ensuite incliné devant le
mémorial juifs les deux hommes ont
préparé le futur voyage du chef de
l'état le premier d'un président
français ce sera en janvier prochain
c'est jacques attali quel est le but de
votre visite en israël bien j'étais
habité depuis longtemps par lui même a
donné une conférence est
j'ai trouvé le temps et l'occasion de la
faire maintenant j'ai fait j'ai profité
de cette occasion pour porter un message
du président mitterrand à monsieur begin
et rencontrent également le président de
l'état d'israël et les dirigeants
travaillistes
c'était donc l'occasion de faire un tour
d'horizon très approfondie des relations
ans qu israël est sur le terrain le plus
amical sur lequel elle se situe
maintenant je dois continuer ce ce
voyage privé par visite au caire ce soit
où je rencontrerai le président sadate
naturellement ceci n'est qu'une privé
qui répare et annonce d'autres beaucoup
plus fort mal est importante cette mise
est relation extérieure qui aimeraient
en israël début décembre et celles du
présent avec l'idée française françois
mitterrand qui viendra aussi à des raids
au début de l'année prochaine donc un
développement des relations franco
israéliennes
vous voyez de l'autre côté du sinaï un
groupe d'intellectuels égyptiens vont
dénoncer aujourd'hui à paris la
répression dans leur pays vous entendrez
l'un d'eux dans notre dernier journal
andreï gromyko devant les nations unies
le ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères a déposé devant l'assemblée
générale de l'onu un projet de
déclaration pour empêcher une
catastrophe nucléaire
il a par ailleurs dénoncé les efforts
considérables at-il dit entrepris par
certains pays occidentaux en vue d'
ébranler les fondements socialiste de
l'état polonais en pologne où une
délégation du gouvernement soviétique
vient d'arriver alors que les autorités
de varsovie ne veulent plus de
négociations ni de coopération avec
solidarité est plus l instant cette
lettre du président reagan
alliant nip régine f le priant regan qui
vient d'adresser donc cette lettre au
président brejnev pour réaffirmer sa
volonté d'établir des relations stables
et constructive avec l'urss une page
médical maintenant en refermant ce
journal évoqué aujourd'hui aux
entretiens de garancière c'est un petit
peu les
mischa de la dentisterie une technique
qui va certainement vous impressionner
les créations de danse ou à repose comme
curé et bien entendu sans douleur une
technique qui peut servir aussi dans
d'autres cas c'est martine arroyo qui
vous la présente deux aiguilles aux
mains de à la base du visage solidement
relier un léger courant électrique dans
nos vingt minutes il n'y aura pas le
moindre autre anesthésique pour extraire
sans douleur une molaire aux deux
racines casseurs c'est l'une des
nombreuses indications de l'acupuncture
en chirurgie dentaire
à une exception près celle des dents de
sagesse incluse
toutes les interventions dans la bouche
peuvent être faite sans douleur ça
titille depuis la suppression de la
douleur est sans doute le plus
spectaculaire mais ce n'est pas le seul
intérêt des petites aiguilles elle se
révèle très efficace aussi pour relaxer
les patients tenaillé par la peur pour
soulager des rages de dents pour éviter
les nausées pendant emprunter radio pour
diminuer la sécrétion de salive et même
évité malaise et syncopes chez les
grands en finale j'ai pas mal ans entre
les stimulations
alors j'ai l'avenir comme si j'étais les
former
cet analgésique utilisé pour toutes les
personnes qui supportent pas la
mystification première chose et
deuxièmement les suites post opératoires
sont merveilleuses c'est à dire qu'il
n'y a pas de douleur postopératoire il
n'y a pas des dames postopératoire avons
veillé à queue pendant les dix à douze
jours qui vont suivre n'aura pas mal dur
pour moi du tout aneb ce soit il veut
retourner à sa vie normale j'ai
normalement comme si rien ne s'était
passé
sauf une petite plaie dans la bouche
vous sentez bien on nage ici par
acupuncture demande une certaine
préparation du malade un certain temps
pour induire la diction de l'analgésique
et un minimum de 20 minutes plus le
temps d'intervention cela demande
beaucoup de rêves donc il faut limiter
l'analgésie par acupuncture chez les
malades qui en ont besoin c'est à dire
les allergiques les cardiaques et les
grands actionnaires et quand ça
coûterait cher
il est évident qu'une séance de nagy par
culture va coûter un peu plus cher
qu'une extraction simple ce qu'il faut
signaler c'est qu'actuellement
l'analgésie par acupuncture n'est pas
encore qualifiée par la cik ptc local
faut compter entre 200 et 500 francs
en plus du tarif sécurité sociale
suivant les interventions elle au
journal dans la banlieue parisienne
yvelines nouvelle c'est un hebdomadaire
de la ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de sa
région
et puis maintenant avec l'embout med la
météo de demain légère amélioration du
temps d'ailleurs voyez on n'hésite pas à
titrer un peu plus de soleil pour ce
mercredi
cela dit c'est vrai on sent que l'été
cet ami nick l'automne approche la carte
pour demain regarder les nuages qui ont
donné pas mal d'orage
aujourd'hui s'éloigne tranquillement
vers le sud est ils vont perdre de
l'intensité sur les massifs montagneux
que ce soit les pyrénées le massif
central le jura les vosges
et puis et les alpes ils atteindront
ensuite dans la journée les la corse
qu'ils quitteront par la suite partout
ailleurs il va se généraliser un temps
comme on dit varia vous savez ce sont
des éclaircies du soleil mais également
des passages nuageux plus nombreux et
plus abondants sur le nord du pays avec
même encore des risques d'averses
principalement au nord de la seine
enfin il faut siffler signale quelque
peu cité de bruit à demain matin
du côté de la bretagne mais ça sentira
assez vite avec l'europe
donc d'éclaircies pour la journée pour
l'après midi un coup d'oeil sur les
températures au pas de grand miracle
elles sont en légère baisse fait
plusieurs jours qu'on s'est habitué à
ces températures moyennes d'une
vingtaine de degrés en général
l'après-midi avec simplement toujours 24
degrés un temps assez lourd est encore
chaud dans le sud-est demain après midi
enfin l'agenda et c'est un petit peu
finalement la grande nouvelle de cette
journée demain c'est l'automne bien une
demi heure avant l'automne alain
valentini ce soir vers 23h30 pour un
journal spécial tgv et puis demain à
midi une radio libre ne rions pas comme
les autres lorraine coeur d'acier à
demain 20 heures
bonsoir à tous